tout ça ce sont des produits qu'on fait
en magasin avec des produits qui sont à
toutes fins utiles en fin de vie franck
hainaut est propriétaire d'un
supermarché sur le plateau mont royal le
gaspillage alimentaire c'est sa bête
noire
chaque matin ses employés font le tour
des comptoirs pour identifier les
produits en fin de vie
certains sont cuisinés sur place
d'autres faire avec des gros rabais
une partie est mise de côté pour les
banques allemandes pour un épicier
indépendant comme nous il ya très
longtemps qu'on gère nos pertes et qu'on
lutte contre le gaspillage parce que
c'est même pas une question de valeurs
c'est une question de survie monsieur il
ya longtemps qu'on fait attention à ce
qu'on met dans nos poubelles
je suis une hausse etc la ville de
montréal veut réglementer les marchés
d'alimentation pour les forcer à réduire
de moitié le gaspillage alimentaire
d'ici 2025
mais pour lui ça n'a aucun sens on n'a
pas besoin d'un gendarme sur n'a pas
besoin de la ville pour nous dire
comment faire notre travail et comment
gérer notre argent et notre inventaire
nous ne sommes pas et je crois que ce
serait dommage de laisser penser à la
population que les épiciers sont des
gaspilleurs comme les restaurateurs ou
autre les statistiques lui donnent
raison de la ferme au frigo des
consommateurs les pertes alimentaires au
canada se chiffre à 50 milliards de
dollars
mais de ce montant la part attribuée à
la vente au détail et d'à peine 10 %
il est possible de faire mieux c'est
vrai mais ce que l'objectif de la ville
50% de réduction en 2025 est trop
ambitieux 2025
cinq ans c'est presque demain si on part
de très très loin parce que là pour
l'instant de même pas de vraiment de
chiffres sur le gaspillage alimentaire à
montréal
mais ce qu'on a comme chef que très très
fragmentaire sais quel gaspillage était
là le chercheur rappelle que les deux
tiers des 150 supermarché de la ville
font déjà des dons aux banques
alimentaires
l heure actuelle on prépare obliger les
entreprises à tout donner leurs invendus
ou a tout donné ce qui ce qui rajoute
actuellement parce que les entre les
organismes ont fait des dons
alimentaires il serait pas outillée
ayant pas les ressources pour gérer les
quantités qui sont jetés à l'heure
actuelle
chez moisson montréal qui gère 15
millions de kg de produits alimentaires
par année on veut bien accepter
davantage mais pas à n'importe quel prix
c'est beau que la ville ou qu'un
organisme réglementaire force détail
alimentaire de données de la banque
alimentaire mais il faut prévoir que des
frais pour aller chercher ça je vous
vois quelqu'un se préoccupe de ce léger
détail
selon richard danon la ville devrait
aussi penser à héberger son champ
d'action ce qu'on ramasse des épiceries
de ces dix douze treize quatorze pour
cent par année ce sont tout marginale ce
qui nous provient des épiciers le gros
du gaspillage alimentaire est en amont
du commerce au détail et chez les
producteurs chez les grossistes chez les
transformateurs effectué riche et chez
chez les maraîchers
on comprend qu'un prolongé en cas dé
l'entreprise de david côté look mission
fabrique des jouets ici même dans
l'entreprise de cochin de la rose en
rachetant une partie des neuf tonnes de
fruits et légumes achetés
quotidiennement par le grossiste ce qui
représente tout juste 2 % de son
inventaire souvent je les regarde puis
je comprends pas pourquoi cela je ne
peux pas croire
et vous il croit qu imposer un règlement
réduit dont ne serait ce que pour four
si l'industrie à revoir ses façons de
faire
c'est qu'on répare les surplus
d'entreprise qui leur coûtait de
l'argent pour jeter des peaux âgées des
entreprises oui autrement c'est
frustrant parce contre une loi qui va
intervenir mais en fait les entreprises
ont rapidement tu rends compte qu'ils
peuvent avoir
les surplus littéralement est ce que
l'objectif 2025 de la ville de montréal
est réaliste ni souhaitable
les avis sont partagés mais on s'entend
au moins sur le problème de fond dans
les dernières décennies on a banalisé le
gaspillage alimentaire ont leur rendu
normal le rendu inévitable on se dit
rappelleront ce fait on peut pas faire
autrement en aiguille on peut faire
autrement